miles teller I'm Glen Powell this is
build your squad championship squad I
don't care what other people are saying
this is the only squad there is we got 7
plus 8 15 bucks to do it he's got seven
bucks I got eight bucks
let's see this this is my wild card just
looking here I'm going burn heggs just
cuz I want to see the wall if I'm going
bang for buck fella long horn Jamaal
Charles now I got five bucks left I
guess I'm going D man Ronny lot that's a
big spent five bucks dude I've wrote a I
wrote a check man my mouth can't cash
I'm actually out of money glad we got
six bucks we only need two guys so we
got six we got six bucks left so I'm
going to bucks on Richard Sherman okay
we got four bucks left I would say we
need a cube well we need a QB we check
the booths for free bucks if we pick my
hoes you guys give up we keep a dollar
future hall-of-famers yeah we get to
keep them going in the homes over young
you spent 500 Ronnie live bees that's
the problem we need a deep in that
impulse our defense is loaded all right
our defense is nobody that was selfish
it was selfish but that's why I have
clicked it all right hypothetically if
we go $3.00 on the home
well I got one player left everything we
only got one player five so you want
young of a homes cuz we need a QB hey
you know what we're going the homes cool
thank you for generosity cool
I mean Jamaal Charles in his prime beast
that's a bargain
mahomes
Jamaal Charles we're doing half back
screens baby let's go changing up the
gameplay honestly murder Hayes can catch
a ball too he's he's a sleeper
wide receiver deep thread we didn't
think this thing through that's well
whatever we're cut we're covering so
that's how fumble recoveries for
touchdowns interceptions that's how
we're winning this game how's an early
$5 spender that ruined our entire game
no way I'm a heavy on Ronnie Lott yeah
miles teller yeah Glen Powell we're here
promoting top chimeric it's a sequel
takes place 30 you know some odd years
after the original Tom Cruise is back as
maverick he's training the the young
guns and it's an incredible movie man we
spent so much time working on it it's
it's really incredible and there's no
green screen so we're up in the Jets the
whole time I mean and there's a
shirtless scene with him and I ya know
yeah that's who take my breath away
that's really aged I'm using lots of oil
be miles is $5 man can't believe you did
it
this is build your squad something